muffets Bob Newhart 60% more influential
than the iPhone 5 shredded cheese in dr.
Ruth's 7% less influential in the urban
dictionary
hey youtubers it's Charlie so Ryan
Reynolds posted this rant video about
Deadpool not being able to go on
Saturday Night Live cuz he completely
trashed his relationship with Lorne
Michaels if you guys aren't big Kanye
fans he had this musical appearance
recently where he had this complete
meltdown backstage I'll play some of the
audio in a second drops a whole bunch of
f-bombs
there's parody videos making fun of that
a lot of people are quoting it as
evidence that he's not gonna be honest
and now Ryan Reynolds could totally do
SNL is Deadpool but I don't think
Deadpool is going to host SNL if it
happened it would be Ryan Reynolds and
they would just do Deadpool things
during it if you haven't seen it there's
a petition that's been going around with
a whole bunch of signatures to get
Deadpool to host SNL the whole idea is
to get Ryan Reynolds to host SNL in
character as Deadpool not hosting his
Ryan Reynolds like actors go on to
promote their movies Ryan Reynolds would
totally do that for the Deadpool movie
but what people want and what it seems
like is not going to happen is Deadpool
himself Ryan Reynolds going full method
and hosting SNL is Deadpool but that
does sound really badass so I'm gonna
play this Kanye clip real quick just
careful for a couple f-bombs that he
drops during it it's pretty funny
by 50% get or live by 50% for the next
thousand years stanley kubrick yay
don't you just love it when Kanye does
silly stuff he is a master at
cultivating negative attention so the
real reason I think that Ryan Reynolds
isn't going to host SNL as Deadpool is
just because it's too weird for normcore
in SNL is kind of norm Cornell really
the best parts of the show now are the
digital shorts that they shoot
separately the live part isn't even the
best part of the show anymore and I
don't even really watch it on a regular
basis so I do like the idea of seeing
Deadpool pop up you know all over TV but
I don't really care if you host SNL or
not I think my favorite superhero
appearance like superhero hosting the TV
show to promote a comic-book movie is
when Kirsten Dunst hosted to promote
spider-man horatio sanz put on the
spider-man costume that was way too
small and descended from the ceiling to
try and get a kiss out of her the rock
is really good too anytime he hosts he's
really good at improv really good at
comedy which are two things you really
need to be awesome on SNL well let me
know in the comments what's your
favorite superhero episode of SNL or
like a superhero actor that's hosted you
Jackman's done a lot that's actually
been quite a few superhero actors that
have hosted SNL in related news what's
gonna happen tonight is I'm gonna do a
king shark flash video there's some new
footage from the king shark episode and
then tomorrow the probably some new Game
of Thrones and new Walking Dead we're
probably gonna see some more comic book
stuff from Walking Dead so if you
haven't caught up with a TV show now's
the time to do it well you guys wait for
me to post that video you can click here
to learn all about the Deadpool sequel
and you can click here to learn all
about the Hulk may be showing up during
civil war thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you